Well, the body of a man was found on a beach in Australia over 70 years ago.
Nobody yet knew that the investigation that would follow would turn it into one
of the country's greatest mysteries there's even today,
we cannot say anything with certainty about what happens on that occasion,
who that man was, how he ended up on that beach, who killed him. And indeed,
if he was even murdered are still questions waiting for an answer.
Was he a spurns lover who decided to end it all?
Or was he actually an international spy who was assassinated within
explicable twists and turns usually found in the pages of a good thriller novel.
This investigation became known worldwide as the mystery of the summer to man or
the Talman should case they will be taken an in-depth look at a real life who
done it, which will include untraceable, poisons, hidden messages,
encrypted codes, rare books, secret love affairs.
And of course a cold blooded murder.
Yeah.
It all started on the morning of December, the first,
1948 on the summit and park beach in Adelaide Australia,
police had arrived at the scene after receiving a call about the body of a
middle-aged man lying in the sand halfway propped up against a sea wall to
horseback riders were the ones who had made the grisly discovery at around 6:00
AM and alerted the authorities after going in for a closer look to make sure
that the man was indeed dead. Police found him to be in his early forties,
smartly dressed, wearing a clean suit and a polished,
a pair of nice shoes in a bus stick in his pocket,
which had purchased the day before indicating that he had not been present in
Summerton earlier that previous afternoon,
he also has an unused second class railway ticket to a nearby suburb named
Henley beach, and Alemanian cone a half empty pack of chewing gum.
The box of matches and strangest of all a pack of army club, brand cigarettes,
which actually contained cigarettes from a different brand called Kansas.
It's awkward.
The neighbors reveals that they had seen a man sitting in that same spot the
night before,
but they all assumes that he was either sleeping or drunk and left him alone.
One couple claimed they saw him around 7:00 PM while out for a stroll and said
at one point,
the man extended one arm upward before letting it fall limp again afterwards,
he remained perfectly still.
Even though there were still many mosquitoes buzzing around his face.
Another couple of saw him later.
And while they thought it was bizarre that the stranger was dressed in a suit at
the beach, they also did not go in closer to investigate.
There were no obvious signs of islands.
So investigators initially concluded that the man became ill,
sat down and propped himself up against the wall for a rest,
fell asleep or passed out and then died during the night. It was unusual,
but hardly had the markings for one of the country's greatest mysteries.
But then the autopsy happens and things started to get weird. First pathologist,
John Barkley Bennett concluded that the mysterious stranger had died no earlier
than 2:00 AM, which means that he was still alive.
When everybody saw him the previous night,
although he had been clearly incapacitated.
Somehow the doctor agreed that the dead man was somewhere between 40 and 45
years old. And that there were no signs of islands on the body. In fact,
he had been in great condition. His body was fixed and his heart was healthy,
even though it was heart failure, which had actually killed him.
This was a bit counter-intuitive to someone who dropped dead on the beach.
So the pathologist started to suspect that foul play might've been involved.
He looked for signs of poisoning and found them.
The pupils were small and unusual.
The spleen was around three times the normal size and the liver,
the kidneys and the stomach were all filled with blood.
Moreover being poisoned would also have explained the stranger's behavior from
the previous night where he had seemingly been alive yet unable to move or
communicate with anyone. Apart from the single arm spasm,
it was starting to look like a clear case of poisoning.
Although whether the man took that poison willingly or not,
we're still inconclusive anyway,
to be sure the pathologist sent samples to a chemistry lab to check for toxins,
which they did and found nothing. No cyanides no alkaloids,
no phenols, no barbiturates, not a trace of any of them.
Later during the investigation, it eminence pharmacologists named sir,
Cedric Stanton Hicks indicated this very potent poison was like the use,
which decomposed soon after his death and left no trace.
He suggested straw fans in or digitalis. Although whether he was right or not,
it became impossible to prove. In the end,
even though the pathologist was convinced that the death could not have been
natural, he could not reach a conclusion regarding the cause of death.
Meanwhile, the police were trying to identify the body,
which the media had taken to calling the summit to man. But the sorts of go on,
there was no wallet with the body. And in fact,
there was no form of identification at all.
His dental records could not be matched to any known person.
And even the labels on his clothes had been removed.
His fingerprints were not found in any Australian database and even reaching out
to international help in Britain and the United States yielded no results.
His photograph was circulated throughout the entire country.
And even though dozens of people came to view the body.
Nobody ultimately recognized him.
The only mind leads that could possibly help with identification were a few
unusual physical traits discovered during the autopsy.
But some of the man had very smooth and soft hands showing no signs of manual
labor, but he had extremely well-developed calf muscles.
The most pronounced that the pathologist had have seen his toes were also
wedge-shaped indicating that the victim more pointed shoes with high heels,
these facts together suggested that maybe the Somerton man had been a ballet
dancer or a long distance runner.
[Inaudible].
Most of the new year,
the police had exhausted all their leads and the summer to man was still a
ghost. Some still argued that his death have been a suicide,
but why would someone develop such a complex method of taking their own life and
more to the point,
how could they do so they would have to first be able to get their hands on a
potent poison that could not be traced back to them.
Then somehow erase all records of their existence and make sure that nobody came
forward to identify them in January authorities.
It widens their investigations to the point where they began examining all
discarded or lost luggage found in Adelaide hotels and railway stations in the
hopes that one of them might've belonged to that victim.
It seems like an act of desperation, but it did produce results. On January.
The 14th staff from the Adelaide railway station came forward with a suitcase
that had been sitting in their cloak room.
Since the morning of November the 30th,
the timing lines up nicely is the previous evidence scanners.
It was also suggested that that was the day that someone to man arrived in
Adelaide, but there was nothing conclusive to connect the two together, even.
So police took what they could get.
The suitcase pretty much contains what you would expect,
a traveling man to have with him. Multiple items of clothing, shaving kit, shoe,
Polish toothbrush, and toothpaste, a table knife,
a pair of scissors and pencils, some handkerchiefs and a lighter.
They're only slightly unusual items in the suitcase where a stenciling brush
typically used for stenciling cargo on merchant ships and a sewing kit
containing a Barbie brand orange wax threads that was not available in Australia
at the time.
One other small clue was the stitch whack on a coat found in the suitcase,
which was unknown in Australia, but was commonly used in America.
These signs pointed to the possibility that the Somerton man may have traveled
to the United States at one point or may have even worked as a sailor like
before all labels and other identifying markers had been painstakingly removed
from the clothing except for three tags with the name T keen on them.
This lead proved to be another dead end though. It was,
nobody was missing by that name in the end of the police concluded that whoever
removed all the other labels left the ones with keen on them because they knew
it was.
Leave nowhere.
If you thought this case was confusing up until this point,
don't worry because they got a whole lot more mysterious in June of 1949,
when a new clue veer to the investigation from unsolved murder into spy thriller
territory and new scientist was brought in to lend his expertise pathology
professor.
So John Burton Clellan in the hopes that he might spot something that everyone
else had missed.
He drew a few conclusions regarding the evidence that had already been analyzed.
For example, we mentioned that the somewhat a man wore nice looking shoes,
but the truth is that they were not simply nice.
They were spotless and did not look like the shoes of a man who walked on the
beach.
There was also no vomit on the clothes or in the area where the victim was
found, which is unusual seeing as the victim was poisons,
this made it Kyle and suspect that the man had been poisoned elsewhere and then
dumped on the beach and capacitated, but still alive in the end,
colons felt pretty confident that the summer to man died from poison,
but he too admitted defeat when it came to establishing the cause of death.
After Cleland was finished with his investigation,
it was time to actually bury the victim.
As the body had started to decompose even say, well,
authorities knew they might have been getting rid of one of their key pieces of
evidence. So they took the unusual precautions of embalming,
the summit of man first, then having plastic costs made of his head and torso.
Finally,
he was buried under concrete and dry grounds to make it easier to exume him,
should the need arise.
The second is more thorough examination of the victim's clothing did yield a
new,
strange and unique piece of evidence inside his trouser pockets had been sewn,
a smaller fob pocket for a watch inside that pocket.
It was a rolled up piece of paper with two words printed on it.
Tom should in Persian, this meant finished or ended.
And the motor itself often became identified as the tem.
I'm sure to case because the words were written in such a distinctive script.
So local police reporter with the Adelaide advertiser named Frank Kennedy
actually recognized where they came from a book of 12th century,
Persian poems calls the Rubaiyat of a marker,
Yom the so-called astronomer poet Persia.
You might think that this is incredibly obscure and archaic,
but the truth is that the poems of remark a yarn were pretty much well known and
popular in the English speaking world. At the time,
following an 1859 translation by English writer, Edward Fitzgerald,
this new evidence made some investigators hope on the suicide bandwagon. Again,
Tom should what the last words in the poetry book and the permit itself was
about living life to the fullest and having no regrets when it was time to die,
the symbolism certainly suggested a person taking their own life.
But of course it also could have easily been staged by someone trying to make it
look like a suicide. In other words, just like up until this point,
the police still knew nothing.
The meaning of the words, Tom shirt aside,
police became interested in the actual book where they came from.
If they could somehow find that particular copy,
maybe they could trace it back to the source where it was bought or borrowed
from which in turn could provide some new clues to the identity of the person
who took it.
They started rummaging through all the bookshops and libraries in Adelaide and
nearby towns, but struck out,
they then put out a public appeal showing the distinctive scripts that the words
were written in and hoped to get lucky, which they did on July the 22nd,
1949, and then only identified under the pseudonym.
Ronald Francis came forward with a copy of the Rubaiyat,
which he saw in the glove box of his brother-in-law's cop.
When he asked his relative about it.
Francis said that somebody threw the book inside the car's backseat through an
open window on November the 30th,
while it was parked one block away from summit to beach,
all signs pointed to this copy of the poetry book being the one where the scrap
of paper came from.
And then the police lined up the torn piece to the page from the book and they
matched up perfectly.
There was no more doubts that this was indeed the correct copy,
but instead of helping to elucidate the mystery, it made it far more bizarre.
For starters,
this was a genuine first edition of the English translation from 1859.
It was rare and valuable. And if it actually belonged to the summit of men,
it was seemingly the only thing of value he possessed.
And yet he treated it with more disdain than any other item casually discarding
it in a random car that he walked by.
And if he did not previously own that book and instead obtained it just to
remove those two words and give us death some kind of symbolic,
meaning why go to the trouble of getting such a rare copy and how come nobody
remembered selling or blending it to em, or simply having it stolen?
There was of course the other possibility that the copy did not belong to the
summit of man and that his killer was in fact,
the one who puts the torn paper in his trouser pocket and who also threw the
book in the back of the car of Ronald Francis,
his brother-in-law even so some of the same questions still applied.
Why are you such a valuable book?
And why didn't anybody report that they sold or lost a copy?
What investigators inferred was that for whatever reason,
it had to be this specific edition,
which the owner probably brought with them from someplace else.
So it could not be traced.
The idea was given credence by two important clues found inside the book.
One was a phone number penciled on the back cover.
The other clue was markings of writing,
which had been scribbled on something which had been placed on top of the book
and then left behind faint indentations.
There were five lines of seemingly random letters of which one line had been
crossed out immediately.
Investigators believe they represented some kind of secret code,
which could have also potentially explained why the book had to be the original
1859 version. The translations varied between different additions.
So if the message was hidden inside the text of the book,
the code might not have worked on any other edition, like all the other clues,
this sounds plausible,
but coming to you remain speculation because the code has never been cracked.
So what about the other leaves? The phone number? It was unlisted,
but police tracked it down to the house of a young woman who lived very close to
somewhat of a beach during the investigation. The name was kept private.
So she was always referred to by the nickname of Justin or the Susan named
Theresa Johnson.
It was only in recent years that our true identity was disclosed with the
family's permission. She was Jessica Thompson at the time,
27 year old nurse who was married to a man named prosper Thompson.
She agreed to cooperate with the investigation.
As long as the name was kept out of it. She went down to the mall.
She couldn't see the body anymore because it had been buried,
but she did look at the pasta casts taken of his head.
Investigators noted her reaction as being odd is Thompson was completely taken
aback and appeared as if she was about to faint.
Given that she had been a nurse during the war,
Thompson had surely seen a lot worse than the plaster cast of a dead body.
So unsurprisingly investigators believed her reaction was caused by a close
connection that she had with the deceased even.
So Thompson then denied knowing who he was. As far as the book was concerned,
she admitted that she once had a copy,
which she gave to a soldier named Alfred Boxall in Sydney during the walk.
She did not go into specifics as to the nature of their relationship.
Although investigators obviously suspected a love of fat for a brief moment.
Police hope that this would finally bring the case to an end. It was a tale.
As old as time,
they thought his Boxall was the jilted lover who decided to take his own life
after visiting the woman. He loved one last time.
There was just a tiny snag in that hypothesis. However,
as they soon discovered that Alfred Boxell was alive and well and working as a
bus maintenance officer in Randwick, not only that,
but he still had his copy of the book complete with the words Tom and should.
And it didn't even turn out to be the 1859 edition anyways.
So well on that idea, I went out to the window.
[Inaudible].
The dead end on the box is all theory, pretty much extinguished.
The last glimmer of hope that investigators had of solving this case.
They'd pursued all the leads in each and every one of them had left the police
more confused and uncertain than before the lack of concrete facts.
In this case,
the led to the appearance of rumors and hypotheses to fill the void.
And one idea that still has a lot of support is that the summit to man had been
a spy. It would explain a lot of the unusual aspects of the case,
the intricate death, the untraceable poison, the book and the code.
Some people even believe that Jessica Thompson had also been a spy.
And this includes our own daughter, Kate and an interview.
Kate recalled that her mother once made a reference to knowing exactly who the
someone to man was, but would not go into detail. And on another occasion,
Jessica admitted to being fluent in Russian. Although she,
again would not say when she learned it,
her family members also think it is possible.
Jessica was having an affair with the summit to man and that our son, Robin,
who was born a year before the summer demand died was actually his Jessica
Thompson passed away in 2007.
So if she did know more about the time and sherd case,
while she took those secrets to a grave,
but what about a date surely with modern technology and forensics,
new leads could be found while there have been a few new developments where the
have mentioned the first one was in 2011,
when an Adelaide woman believed she had identified the summer to madness British
sailor, HC Reynolds among her father's old possessions.
She found the ID account of a man identified as Reynolds who served in world war
one and bore a striking similarity to the summit.
A man will be as 30 years younger,
she took the photograph to a biological anthropologists to compare the image
photos of the summer to man and computers that the shape was very similar and
also found a mole, which was in the same location on both men,
others disagree with this identification,
claiming that they pieced together the life of a sailor from available records
and that the real Reynolds died in 1953.
Another private investigation is being led by professor Derek Abbott from the
university of Adelaide who has been researching the summit of man for over a
decade Abbott and his team have approached the case from two angles.
One involves cracking the code and the other using DNA to identify the body.
The first isn't going so well,
the team has managed to eliminate numerous types of ciphers,
but the most likely scenario is that the code needs the original 1859 poetry
book to work, which has since been lost.
And they have been unable to secure another copy.
The DNA is showing more promise for years,
Abbott has been unsuccessful in his efforts to convince the South Australian
government to exhume the body of the summit to man,
because he could improve eight significance and legitimate reason for us.
This changed in October, 2017,
when he received a few has from the plastic cost made of the to man decades ago
and was able to analyze mitochondrial DNA from that sample Abbott's latest
efforts swayed the current South Australian attorney general,
who approved an exhumation order late last year,
obviously given the current global situation,
this has been put on the back burner,
but it is still possible that one day soon we will discover his true identity
and solve the mystery of the summit of man.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and thank you for watching.